>>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
ARE WE STOPPING?
>> YEAH, I'VE GOT TO GET SOME
CASH.
>> IN THERE?
>> THAT'S A BANK, ISN'T IT.
>> I JUST -- I WOULDN'T STOP IN
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> RELAX, IT WILL BE LIKE TWO
MINUTES.
>> OKAY, BUT HURRY.
>> YO, HOLD THAT DOOR.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU CAN GO AHEAD IF
YOU WANT TO.
>> NO, MAN, YOU WERE FIRST.
>> I'M NOT REALLY IN A HURRY.
IT'S FINE.
DO YOU WANT TO --
>> NEITHER AM I.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S SILLY, I THINK
I GRABBED THE WRONG CARD.
>> OH, I GET IT.
A BLACK MAN FOLLOWS YOU IN HERE
DRESSED LIKE THIS, AND NOW ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU GRABBED THE
WRONG CARD, HUH?
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> I WORK MY ASS OFF 60 HOURS A
WEEK SO I DON'T HAVE TO STEAL
FROM YOU OR ANYBODY ELSE, ALL
RIGHT.
>> IT'S LATE, OKAY, YOU RAN IN
HERE.
I GUESS I GOT A LITTLE RATTLED
ALL RIGHT?
>> WELL, HEY HERE'S A TIP.
NOT EVERY BLACK MAN IS A DAMN
THIEF YOU RACIST BASTARD.
>> OKAY, I'M SORRY.
I SWEAR I'M NOT A RACIST, OKAY.
>> WELL THEN GO FIRST.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FINE.
I'M GOING TO GO.
[ BEEPING ]
>> MAN, AIN'T YOU GOING TO COUNT
IT, MAKE SURE IT'S ALL RIGHT?
>> YEAH, IT'S ALL HERE.
>> WELL THEN GIVE IT TO ME.
GIVE ME THE MONEY.
>> HEY, MAN, I'M --
>> AHH, I'M JUST KIDDING.
MAN, LOOK HOW SCARED YOU WERE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT, RIGHT.
WE GOTTA STOP THAT.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, MAN.
>> OKAY, MAN.
HEY MAN, I'M SORRY AGAIN.
I THANK YOU FOR -- I'M NOT A
RACIST.
>> DON'T SWEAT IT MAN, BUT HEY
MAYBE NEXT TIME DON'T FREAK OUT
JUST BECAUSE A BLACK MAN WANTS
TO USE THE ATM MACHINE.
>> ALRIGHT. FAIR ENOUGH.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
SORRY, MAN.
>> YO, HOLD THAT DOOR, MAN.
>> OH MY GOD, PLEASE, DON'T.
>> HEY, WHAT'S UP, MAN.
HOW YOU FEELING?
LOOK BITCH, ARE YOU GOING TO USE
THAT MACHINE, OR WHAT?
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS CAN JUST GO
AHEAD.
>> NO, I WANT TO GO SECOND.
I'M MAD PATIENCE.
>> THE THING IS I MIGHT HAVE
GRABBED THE WRONG CARD.
>> TRY IT ANYWAY THOUGH DOG.
I'M FEELING LUCKY.
GO AHEAD, YEAH, BE BRAVE.
HEY WATCH YOURSELF BIG MAN.
HURRY UP BITCH, COME ON.
WHAT YOU NERVOUS A BLACK MAN
WALKING IN HERE JUST WANT TO USE
THE ATM BRO.
>> NO, MY BROTHER.
>> WHAT IS TAKING SO LONG.
>> THE CARD DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
WORKING.
>> TRY IT AGAIN DOG.
COME ON.
BREATHE, MAN.
ARE YOU CRYING?
>> NO.
>> I'M TIRED OF WAITING ON YOU
DOG.
>> I WANT TO GO HOME.
>> SUCK IT UP MAN.
>> EVERYTHING OKAY?
>> CAN WE GET OUT OF HERE?
I SAW SOME SKETCHY LOOKING GUYS
EARLIER.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN, SKETCHY?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY WERE --
>> BLACK?
YOU KNOW, HONEY, YOU CAN'T JUST
JUDGE PEOPLE BY THE WAY THEY
LOOK.
YOU KNOW?
I MEAN FOR ALL YOU KNOW THEY
WERE HARD WORKING, HONEST PEOPLE
JUST LIKE US.
[ YELLING ]
>> GOD, YOU'RE RIGHT.
[ GROANS ]
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU JUST ROB THE
WHITE GUY?
I WOULD HAVE HELPED YOU GUYS.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK REALLY
BEAUTIFUL.
>> WHOA, WHOA, NO KISSING.
>> OH, THAT'S RIGHT, BECAUSE
YOUR A PROSTITUTE.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S THE RULE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪